que la crisis del deseo es frecuentemente una crisis de la imaginación.
Así que, ¿por qué el buen sexo a menudo se desvanece?
¿Cuál es la relación entre amor y deseo?
¿Cómo se relacionan y cómo entran en conflicto?
Porque ahí radica el misterio del erotismo.
Si hay un verbo, para mí, que acompañe a amor es "tener".
Y si hay un verbo que acompañe a deseo, es "querer".
En el amor, queremos tener, queremos conocer lo amado.
Queremos minimizar la distancia. Queremos reducir la brecha.
Queremos neutralizar las tensiones. Queremos cercanía.
Pero al desear, tendemos a no regresar a los lugares en los que ya hemos estado.
Los resultados previsibles no mantienen nuestro interés.
Al desear, queremos un Otro, alguien del otro lado que podamos ir a visitar,
con quien podamos pasar algún tiempo,
que podamos ir a ver qué pasa en la zona roja.
Al desear, queremos un puente para cruzar.
En otras palabras, a veces digo, el fuego necesita aire.
El deseo necesita espacio.
Y cuando se dice así es bastante abstracto.
Pero luego tomé una pregunta conmigo.
Y he ido a más de 20 países en los últimos años
con "Inteligencia Erótica" y le pregunté a la gente,
¿cuándo encuentra más atractiva a su pareja?
No atractiva sexualmente, per se, sino más deseable.
Y a lo largo de las culturas, las religiones, el género
—excepto por uno— hubo pocas respuestas diferentes.
El primer grupo es: Es más deseable para mí
cuando se va, cuando está lejos, cuando nos reunimos.
Básicamente, cuando entro en contacto
con mi habilidad de imaginarme con mi pareja,
cuando mi imaginación regresa al cuadro,
y cuando puedo socavar en la ausencia y el anhelo,
que es el mayor componente del deseo.
Pero un segundo grupo es aún más interesante:
Me es más deseable
cuando la veo en el estudio, cuando está en escena,
cuando está en su elemento, haciendo algo que le apasiona,
cuando la veo en una fiesta y con otras personas,
cuando la veo dirigiendo.
Básicamente, cuando veo a mi pareja radiante y segura,
probablemente el mayor excitante de todos.
Radiante, como autosuficiente.
Veo a esa persona, por cierto, en el deseo
las personas raramente hablan de ello, cuando estamos mezclados en uno,
a 5 centímetros uno de otro. No sé en pulgadas cuánto es.
Pero tampoco es cuando la otra persona está tan lejos
que ya no puedes verla.
Es cuando veo a mi pareja a una distancia confortable,
cuando esa persona que es ya tan familiar, saben,
es por momentos, misteriosa otra vez, algo elusiva.
Y en ese espacio entre yo y el otro reside el impulso erótico,
reside el movimiento hacia el otro.
Porque a veces, como decía Proust,
el misterio no es viajar a nuevos lugares,
sino verlos con nuevos ojos.
Y así, cuando veo mi pareja por su cuenta,
haciendo algo en que está involucrada,
veo a esa persona y por momentos tengo un cambio de percepción,
y estoy abierta a los misterios que viven justo a mi lado.
Y entonces, más importante, en esta descripción del otro
o de mí —es lo mismo—, lo que es más interesante
es que no hay necesidad en el deseo.
Nadie necesita a nadie.
No hay cuidado en el deseo.
El cuidado es muy amoroso. Es un potente antiafrodisiaco.
Todavía estoy por ver a alguien que esté excitado
por alguien que lo necesita.
Una cosa es quererles. Necesitarlos es un freno,
y las mujeres lo han sabido desde siempre,
porque cualquier cosa que lleve a la planificación
generalmente disminuirá la carga erótica.
Por buenas razones, ¿correcto?
Y el tercer grupo de respuestas generalmente son:
Cuando estoy sorprendido, cuando reímos juntos,
como alguien me dijo en la oficina hoy,
cuando está de etiqueta, así que me dije, ya sabes,
es o de etiqueta o de botas de vaquero.
Pero básicamente es cuando hay novedad.
Pero la novedad no se trata de nuevas posiciones. No es un repertorio de técnicas.
Novedad es, ¿qué partes tuyas vas a mostrar?
¿Qué partes de ti casi se ven?
Porque de alguna manera uno podría decir
que el sexo no es algo que uno hace, ¿eh?
El sexo es un lugar al que vas. Es un espacio al que entras
dentro de ti mismo y con otro, u otros.
¿Así que a dónde irías en el sexo?
¿Qué partes de ti conectas?
¿Qué buscas expresar allí?
¿Es un lugar para la trascendencia y unión espiritual?
¿Es un lugar para la travesura y es un lugar para ser agresivo con seguridad?
¿Es un lugar donde puedes rendirte
y no tener que asumir la responsabilidad de todo?
¿Es un lugar donde puedes expresar tus deseos infantiles?
¿Qué viene por ahí? Es un lenguaje.
No es solo un comportamiento.
Y es la poética de ese idioma lo que me interesa,
que es por lo que comencé a explorar este concepto de inteligencia erótica.
Saben, los animales tienen sexo.
Es el pivote, es biología, es el instinto natural.
Somos los únicos que tienen una vida erótica,
lo que significa que es sexualmente transformada por la imaginación humana.
Somos los únicos que pueden hacer el amor durante horas,
pasar un rato feliz, tener orgasmos múltiples,
sin tocar a nadie, simplemente porque nos lo imaginamos.
Podemos esbozarlo. Ni siquiera tenemos que hacerlo.
Podemos experimentar esa cosa potente llamada anticipación,
que es el mortero del deseo,
la capacidad de imaginar, como si estuviera sucediendo,
para vivirlo como si estuviera sucediendo, mientras que nada está sucediendo
y todo está ocurriendo al mismo tiempo.
Así que cuando empecé a pensar sobre el erotismo,
me puse a pensar en la poética del sexo,
y si lo veo como una inteligencia,
entonces es algo que puedes cultivar.
¿Cuáles son los ingredientes? Imaginación, alegría,
novedad, curiosidad, misterio.
Pero el agente central es realmente esa pieza llamada la imaginación.
Pero lo más importante, para yo comenzar a entender
cuáles son las parejas que tienen una chispa erótica,
lo que mantiene el deseo, tuve que volver
a la definición original de erotismo,
la definición mística, y me fui a través de ella
a través de una bifurcación mirando realmente al trauma,
que es la otra cara, y mirarla,
mirando a la comunidad en que había crecido,
que era una comunidad en Bélgica, todos sobrevivientes del Holocausto,
y en mi comunidad había dos grupos:
los que no murieron y los que volvieron a la vida.
Y los que no murieron vivieron a menudo muy atados a la tierra,
no podría experimentar placer, no podía confiar,
porque cuando estás atento, preocupado, ansioso,
e inseguro, no puedes levantar la cabeza
e ir y despegar al espacio y ser juguetón y seguro e imaginativo.
Los que regresaron a la vida fueron aquellos
que entendieron lo erótico como un antídoto a la muerte.
Supieron cómo mantenerse vivos.
Y cuando comencé a escuchar de la asexualidad de las parejas con las que trabajo,
a veces les oigo decir, "Quiero más sexo",
pero por lo general lo que la gente quiere es mejor sexo,
y lo mejor es volver a conectar con esa cualidad de estar vivo,
de resonancia, de renovación, de vitalidad, de eros, de energía
que el sexo solía darles o que habían esperado
les diera.
Y así empecé a hacer una pregunta diferente.
"Me apago cuando..." empezó a ser la pregunta.
"Se me acaba el deseo cuando..." que no es la misma pregunta,
"Lo que me apaga es..." y "Me apagas el deseo cuando..."
Y la gente comenzó a decir, "No tengo deseo cuando
me siento muerto dentro, cuando no me gusta mi cuerpo,
cuando me siento viejo, cuando no he tenido tiempo para mí,
cuando no he tenido oportunidad ni siquiera de presentarme,
cuando no lo hago bien en el trabajo,
cuando siento baja autoestima, cuando no tengo un sentido de ser valioso,
cuando no me siento como que tengo el derecho a querer,
de recibir placer".
Y entonces empecé a hacer la pregunta inversa.
"Me excito cuando..." Porque la mayoría de las veces,
a la gente le gusta hacer pregunta, "Me excito,
lo que me excita", y estoy fuera de la pregunta. ¿Saben?
Ahora, si estás muerto dentro, la otra persona puede hacer muchas cosas por San Valentín.
No hará mella. No hay nadie en la recepción.
(Risas)
Así que me excito cuando,
dirijo a mis deseos, me avivo cuando...
Ahora, en esta paradoja entre el amor y el deseo,
lo que parece ser tan desconcertante es que los propios ingredientes
que nutren el amor —mutualismo, reciprocidad,
protección, preocupación, responsabilidad por el otro—
son a veces los mismos ingredientes que sofocan el deseo.
Porque el deseo viene con una serie de sentimientos
que no siempre favorecen el amor:
celos, posesividad, agresión, poder, dominación,
malicia, travesuras.
Básicamente la mayoría de nosotros no excitamos en la noche
por las mismas cosas contra la que protestamos durante el día.
Saben, la mente erótica no es muy políticamente correcta.
Si todo el mundo fantasea en un lecho de rosas,
no tendríamos esas conversaciones interesantes sobre esto.
Pero no, en nuestra mente
hay una multitud de cosas sucediendo que no siempre sabemos
cómo llevar a la persona que amamos,
porque pensamos que el amor viene con abnegación,
y de hecho el deseo viene con una cierta cantidad de egoísmo
en el mejor sentido de la palabra:
la capacidad de estar conectado al propio yo
en presencia de otro.
Así que quiero traer esa pequeña imagen hacia Uds.,
debido a esta necesidad de conciliar estos dos grupos de necesidades
con las que nacemos.
Nuestra necesidad de conexión, nuestra necesidad de separación,
o nuestra necesidad de seguridad y aventura,
o nuestra necesidad de estar juntos y de autonomía,
y si piensan en el niño que está sentado en su regazo
y que es acunado allí, muy seguro y cómodo,
y en algún momento todos debemos salir al mundo
para descubrir y explorar.
Eso es el principio del deseo,
necesidades exploratorias, curiosidad, descubrimiento.
En algún momento dan vuelta y miran
y si les dices:
"Niño, el mundo es un gran lugar. Ve por él.
Hay mucha diversión allá",
entonces pueden dar vuelta y experimentar
conexión y separación al mismo tiempo.
Pueden ir en su imaginación, en su cuerpo,
disfrutando su alegría, sabiendo todo el tiempo
que habrá alguien cuando regresen.
Pero si en este lado hay alguien que dice:
"Me preocupa. Estoy ansioso. Estoy deprimido.
Mi pareja no ha cuidado de mí en tanto tiempo.
¿Qué hay tan bueno allá afuera? ¿No tenemos todo lo que
necesitamos juntos, tú y yo?",
entonces hay algunas pocas reacciones
que todos nosotros podemos reconocer bien.
Algunos de nosotros volveremos, regresar a hace mucho tiempo
y a ese niño que regresa
es el niño que va renunciar a una parte de sí mismo
para no perder el otro.
Perderé mi libertad para no perder la conexión.
Y aprenderé a amar de una cierta manera
que vendrá cargada de preocupación extra,
responsabilidad y protección adicionales,
y no sé cómo dejarte
para jugar, para experimentar placer,
con el fin de descubrir, de entrar dentro de mí.
Traduzcan esto al lenguaje adulto.
Empieza muy joven. Continúa en nuestra vida sexual
hasta el final.
El niño número dos regresa
pero pareciera que sobre sus hombros todo el tiempo.
"¿Vas a estar allí?
¿Vas a maldecirme? ¿Vas a regañarme?
¿Vas a estar enojada conmigo?"
Y se ha ido, pero nunca están muy lejos,
y son a menudo las personas que les dirán,
al principio era supercaliente.
Porque en un principio, la intimidad creciente
no era aún tan fuerte
que realmente llevara a la disminución del deseo.
Cuanto más conectado estoy, más responsable me siento,
menos soy capaz de irme de tu presencia.
El tercer niño realmente no regresa.
Entonces pasa que, si quieres sostener el deseo,
es este pedazo de real dialéctica.
Por un lado deseas la seguridad para poder ir.
Por otra si no puedes irte, no tienes placer,
no puedes culminar, no tienes un orgasmo,
que no te excitas porque gastas tu tiempo
en el cuerpo y la cabeza del otro y no en el tuyo propio.
En este dilema sobre reconciliación de
estos dos grupos de necesidades fundamentales,
hay algunas pocas cosas que me han llevado a comprender lo que hacen esas parejas eróticas.
Uno, tienen mucha intimidad sexual.
Entienden que hay un espacio erótico que
pertenece a cada uno de ellos.
También entienden que la estimulación erótica no es algo que haces
cinco minutos antes de la cosa real.
El juego erótico inicia al final del anterior orgasmo.
También entienden que un espacio erótico
no es sobre comenzar a tocar al otro.
Es sobre crear un espacio donde dejas el Directivo S.A.
tal vez donde dejas el programa 'Agile',
(Risas)
y realmente solo debes entrar a ese lugar
donde dejas de ser el buen ciudadano
que cuida de las cosas y es responsable.
Responsabilidad y deseo solo pelean.
Realmente no lo hacen bien juntos.
Las parejas eróticas también entiendan que la pasión aumenta y disminuye.
Es bastante parecida a la Luna. Tiene eclipses intermitentes.
Pero lo que saben es que saben cómo resucitarla.
Saben cómo hacerla regresar,
y saben cómo hacerla regresar
porque han desmitificado un gran mito,
que es el mito de la espontaneidad, que es
que vas a caer del cielo mientras tú estás doblando la ropa
como un deus ex machina, y de hecho entendieron
que todo lo que va a pasar, solo pasa
en una relación de largo plazo que ya se tiene.
Sexo comprometido es sexo premeditado.
Es con voluntad. Es intencional.
Es foco y presencia.
Feliz San Valentín.
(Aplausos)